we don't know how many fans will be in
the stands this year and which stadiums
will be able to have fans what we do
know is that in the first six to eight
rows of all stadiums
the seats will be covered with tarps and
advertising will be on those tarps
because the bottom line is this if fans
are present you want to have a buffer
zone between the fans and the sidelines
you don't want somebody
up speaking so loudly or spitting or
doing anything that would send potential
droplets with virus down in the range of
the of the player area you don't want
people throwing things that they've
touched down that way so that that's the
idea that's what the nfl is doing and
they have indeed decided to do that it's
not really surprising especially when
you consider it's an opportunity to
recapture revenue that's going to be
lost
if
and when there is a reduction in the
number of fans that can be present for
the game so it's it's not really a
win-win because the ultimate win is to
have everybody in the stadiums like
usual but this is more like making a
small batch of chicken salad out of a
giant pile of
of chicken something else big cat
those seats stink anyway mike also i
just wanted on the record i wanted to be
noted in the pro football talk uh
history books that you rushed us to
break after you quoted the unbelievable
philosopher atlantis more set so i just
want to make sure that the record shows
that okay so i these first eight rows
have you sat in one of these
but wait but wait but wait did did that
to you did that feel like wayne rain on
your wedding day is that is that the uh
emotion you had
10 000 spoons when all you use a knife
the first eight rows stink in a for in a
football stadium so i you know it's
actually almost a blessing like if i
were if they do allow fans
and there are the first eight rows that
are that are covered up and i were
someone that that got pushed eight rows
back i'd be thrilled i'd be absolutely
thrilled if there's that front row in a
football stadium it it's not watchable
the first time i ever saw the vikings
play was at three rivers stadium
and out in the parking lot i did the
upgrade from the tickets that i had to
the front row hey i got the front row
you get down in the front row you can't
see anything all you see is the backs of
the players that's it now you hear some
interesting things and the vikings got
manhandled that day and we were right
behind their bench and i heard a lot of
words that i already knew because i was
in my 20s but i tell you what it was it
was loud and it was profane and it was
access you otherwise don't get but you
don't get to see the football game
front row for baseball and basketball
300s for hockey and football that's how
it should always be that's how you watch
the game
all right well those seats will be
filled or at least covered this year and
it's still not known what
the the teams are collectively going to
do and big cat something we talked about
yesterday i want to get your thoughts on
this
because it occurred to me earlier this
week i was on the score in chicago with
dan bernstein and we were talking about
this whole dynamic of no fans and what
may happen outside the stadium you know
if there are places where they don't let
fans in but there isn't a stay-at-home
order you could have thousands of people
congregating in the parking lot treating
it like any other game day tailgating
watching the game on tv having a
communal experience
and nobody can get inside
and the nfl is anticipating that and i
think some teams are already plotting
how they could make money off of that
you can supply the beer and you can
supply some food and you can charge
people to park there and you know if
they if they say no we can't have this
this isn't safe whatever perimeter they
set up on the other side of that
perimeter that's where everyone's going
to congregate so that this really i mean
this
this
this broader season of the twilight zone
has plenty of episodes left and one of
them will consist of
raucous loud drunken behavior in the
parking lot outside of an empty stadium
and you throw on top of the frustration
that you can't get in and there'll
probably be a hell of a lot more
violence outside than there ever would
be inside
i don't know that seems like we're now
getting really doomsday like worrying
about everything i i mean will people
tailgate
but
uh i'm just i don't know what do you
think they're gonna do in buffalo do you
think they're gonna stay away from the
stadium in buffalo if they can't get in
do you think those fans are not gonna
show up
no but i don't so i'm not gonna add i'm
not gonna add increased violence to the
to the list not like
i don't know we we
i'm talking about i'm talking about
people out in the out in the parking lot
watching the game out there drinking all
day long drinking and drinking and
drinking and you throw on the
frustration that they're not inside when
they want to be inside that's that extra
that's that extra match thrown into the
under into the into the pile of of
leaves that's my point i'm i'm not i i
don't buy that as a real issue and i
also don't uh think you know drinking
and drinking and drinking all day is any
different than a regular nfl season
that's that's a reality of it that that
either you realize or you don't and
you're you know you're ignorant to the
world and you think that people have
like two beers and they get in their car
and they're fine
well it's i think it's going to be a
factor that they have to deal with and
other things that they have to deal with
and they're not
disclosing anything yet there was a
conference call yesterday with several
different people from the league and
look they're talking about what they're
going to do with rosters i think that's
a real issue because it's one thing to
have procedures in place
to keep the players from getting or
spreading the virus it's another thing
to have procedures in place to backfill
your roster when you have an outbreak if
you have an outbreak and expanding the
practice squad from 12 to 16 which has
been discussed that's not going to be
good enough if you lose 10 15 20 guys
all of a sudden because they're all
positive at the same time what are you
going to do to get players they got to
address a lot of things and a lot of
issues and you know baseball's doing it
because baseball is on the way back and
i think the nfl is going to study
baseball and study what happens with the
nba and is studying what's happening
with the premier league in england but
there's a lot to do they still intend
big cat to start training camp july 28th
that is one month and two days from now
32 days away is the start of training
camp there's a lot to do and not a lot
of time in which to get it done and they
haven't done a lot by way of letting
people know what they're planning which
i think creates this sense of confusion
and uncertainty among fans and media
that they really do have a plan now i
think they do have a plan and i think
they're working hard at some point
though they have to share some of those
details so the rest of us can say okay
we feel we feel a lot better about this
than when we do when we're kept
completely in the dark
to be honest they're probably doing what
all of us have been doing and that is to
just hope that as every day passes that
we uh something miracle happens and we
have a vaccine or the virus just goes
away i mean let's just be honest mike
that's what that's what's been going
through my head and that's what's been
going through a lot of people's head so
i wouldn't be shocked that the nfl has
something similar going through their
head where they're saying look we'll
start planning stuff but maybe also
come july come august it will just be
poof gone and we'll be good to go
if that is anywhere
in the range of plan a b c d e or f you
better get ready to take
gus duggerton to the nfl and play like
10 different seasons this year and and
uh because
that that's not to me a viable solution
and i do believe i do believe
that there is confidence they're going
to get this worked out i do believe they
know a lot more than we do about how the
virus operates i believe and big cat you
haven't been here since we talked about
this and i learned about it last
saturday there is a strong belief among
folks in the nfl that outdoor
transmission is so much more difficult
to accomplish than indoor and confined
spaces they believe that the bulk and i
think this is the prevailing thought now
among the experts although it's hard to
get the straight story uh through the
media because it's all over the place
the prevailing thought is that the
predominant risk
is confined space transmission that that
all the kids that are getting it at
clemson and elsewhere they're in the
weight room most likely that's how
they're getting it exhaling and and the
droplets hang in the air and other guys
walk into that cloud with their eyes and
their noses getting the virus outdoor
transmission
big under you know under a dome
type type situation where
it can all dissipate there's a strong
belief that there will not be
transmission in those settings now if
they're wrong we won't have football if
they're right they should be able to
work it out
yeah well i'm just hoping for football i
just you know i've given up on uh any
rational thought because i don't have
rational thoughts anymore mike we've all
gone crazy have you ever have you ever
yeah time to time time to time i'll have
a good thought that will pop in my head
time to time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports